le 236 rectifié quoi de terre de
monsieur ça va alors je voudrais juste
monsieur ça va préciser à madame boyer
que son amendement sont sous amendement
n'est pas retenue si vous voulez des
explications ou simplement parce que
monsieur ça va a modifié son amendement
du coup le vôtre ne peut plus être
retenu comme un sous-amendement donc
qu'il est retiré
merci à vous monsieur avant votre
amendement merci mesdames le président
russe
des principes de neutralité des services
publics et de la laïcité
ainsi rien n'interdit le port de signes
religieux
je tiens à souligner je parle ici de
tout signe religieux avec cet amendement
les règlements de ces établissements
devront donc garantir le respect de ces
principes de neutralité et de laïcité
actuellement seuls les règlements
intérieurs en cas d' les vêtements
autorisé de point de vue de l'hygiène et
de la sécurité
or ces règlements sont laissées à
l'appréciation des maires ce que nous
pouvons constater c'est que certains de
ces mères peuvent être soumis à de
fortes pressions communautaires d'autres
peuvent être aussi céder à des
tentations clientéliste voir promouvoir
une vision de la société contraire à nos
principes républicains
un exemple ces dernières années dans mon
département la ville de grenoble comme
d'autres villes a été le théâtre d'actes
de désobéissance civile de la part de
militants en burqini qui ont enfreint
les règlements intérieurs au nom de la
liberté les femmes à vivre leur foi
comme elles l'entendent et ses actes de
provocation médiatisées ont créé une
vive polémique nationale le maire
écologiste de grenoble n'est jamais
sorti de son ambiguïté il a appelé à la
responsabilité de l'état je le cite si
c'est une question de laïcité le
gouvernement doit prendre position
ce moment de responsabilité mes
collègues nous y sommes avec ce projet
de loi comme l'a dit votre collègue
marlène schiappa vendredi dernier il y
un combat culturel à mener nous faisons
face à une petite minorité qui promeut
un islam radical et rétrograde notamment
pour les femmes d'autre part monsieur le
ministre de l'intérieur vous avez
indiqué que sous couvert de combattre
l'islamophobie
certaines associations font pression sur
les pouvoirs publics pour promouvoir des
règles compatible avec la charia
nous savons tous cette pression est de
plus en plus forte en france est de la
responsabilité de l'état de ne pas
laisser les mères seules en première
ligne de petites compromissions en grand
renoncement le risque de voir
progressivement les dykes cédé au gré
des spécificités sociologique et
politique des territoires
or c'est bien l'ambition de cette loi
que de préserver l'unité du pays autour
de nos principes républicains qui se
fissurent peu à peu
la liberté de culte est un bien précieux
dans notre pays ne doit pas être une
porte ouverte d organisation
communautariste qui veulent faire
prospérer un projet politique ou
religieux à l'opposé de nos valeurs
merci madame la rapporteure alors nous
avons discuté d'un premier amendement
déposé par notre collègue c'est sa main
ce matin en commission et nous avions
dans la forme initiale au niveau de la
commission des lois a mis un avis
défavorable et ce soir nous avons
réexaminé
cet amendement 236 dans une version
rectifiée qui précise que le règlement
d'utilisation d'une piscine aux
baignades artificielles public à usage
que les ti garantit le respect des
principes de neutralité des
scientifiques et de laïcité et la
commission a émis un avis favorable à
cet amendement
monsieur le ministre votre avis oui
c'est une question évidemment très
importante que vous posez monsieur le
sénateur mais je voudrais dire pourquoi
je suis défavorable à votre un moment
pour trois raisons la première c'est que
aujourd'hui la loi permet aux
collectivités locales en effet
d'interdire des vêtements dits religieux
pour deux motifs non pas des motifs
religieux ce serait contre la
constitution est content intégration
droits de l'homme un motif d'ordre
public et un motif d'hygiène d'ailleurs
j'ai pris la défense chacun l'aura
constaté de madame la présidente de la
région ile de france
lorsque dans le règlement intérieur
prévu pour les bases de loisirs de la
région ile de france
la défenseur des droits a évoqué le fait
que ce règlement intérieur était
discriminatoire
c'est évidemment pas la lecture que j'ai
de la loi de la république piano
contraire et que c'est bien fondées que
les îles de la république peuvent
interdire dans le règlement intérieur
dans les lieux publics et dans les lieux
gérés par délégation de service public
pour des motifs d'ordre public ou pour
des motifs de
d'hygiène des vêtements qui ne serait
pas conforme à la tradition d'accès et
notamment au burkina mais pas que
premier point deuxièmement je voudrais
quand même rappeler à monsieur le
sénateur que je me permets de le faire
avec ça c'est si que la libre
administration des collectivités locales
ne me permet pas d'interdire de fait des
dispositions qui relèvent de la
compétence stricto sensu des élus dans
le cadre de la loi
et bien vous avez bien raison de
souligner le communautarisme où le
clientélisme ou la naïveté mais
peut-être que ce troisième point
désormais n'est plus tout à fait lors du
jour de certaines collectivités locales
notamment de la ville de grenoble qui a
organisée sciemment par ailleurs avec
souvent des associations subventionnées
ceci ramène à jour cela donc je constate
d'ailleurs que vous aurez constaté que
les associations évoqués sont soit
dissoute au conseil des ministres depuis
notre arrivée au gouvernement soit
proposé à la commission européenne pour
fin de subventions c'est le cas
d'alliance citoyenne par exemple mais je
me vois mal monsieur le sénateur te
prendre un terme législatif pour imposer
aux collectivités locales ce qui relève
de leur responsabilité et la liberté de
la libre administration des
collectivités locales c'est la liberté
aussi d'assumer ses décisions politiques
vis-à-vis de ses citoyens parce qu'ils
ne sont pas contraires profondément à
l'ordre public et aux organes qui font
la salubrité puis troisièmement monsieur
le sénateur l'expression religieuse je
voudrais leur dire des usages et
services publics débat que nous avons
précédemment est consacré par la
déclaration de renommée citoyens elle
est consacrée par la constitution elle
est consacrée par notre état de droit et
que nous ne pouvons pas privé par
principe
c'est ce que vous proposez dans votre
amendement l'expression d'une opinion
religieuse et la neutralité ne s'impose
pas aux usagers du service public parce
que le problème et je peux tout à fait
le comprendre ce qui concerne cette
provocation du burkini mais allons nous
demain interdire le port d'un signe
religieux dans un autobus qui est un
espace de service public délégué par le
service public
allons-nous le faire sous un abribus
j'ai même entendu à l'assemblée
nationale des députés qui vous légiférez
aux abords immédiats du service public
comme un parvis d'une mairie je pense
que ce n'est pas de bonne facture que de
faire la loi dans cette façon de me
semble-t-il
zale lô au contraire un sécurisé et quel
message serait donnée d'une censure de
ces dispositions
quant au contraire nous voulons
encourager les élus de la république à
prendre des dispositions qui sont déjà
prévues par la loi mais elle demande
effectivement un peu de courage
politique j'aurais dire monsieur le
sénateur qu'on n'est jamais obligée de
céder au communautarisme et qu'on n'est
jamais obligée de céder au clientélisme
religieux et vous savez parmi les
dispositions de la loi je suis allé voir
monsieur président de l'association des
maires de france avec une disposition
qui me paraissait encore plus intrusif
peut-être que la vôtre notamment sur les
permis de construire délivrés pour les
offices pour les lieux cultuels parce
que j'avais pu constater que dans des
endroits particuliers de la république
quand la population d'une certaine
religion était trop nombreuse il est
difficile pour l'élu de récuser et de ne
pas vouloir signer un permis de
construire pour une association
cultuelle pour construire notre culte et
j'avais proposé qu'on transfère ce
permis de construire au préfet le préfet
après tout était une décharge facile
il est à deux ou trois ans dans le
territoire et peut endosser quelque
chose de plus difficile vis-à-vis des
citoyen de telle ou telle commune et
c'est le président des maires de france
françois baroin lui-même qui m'a tout en
comprenant bien évidemment je voudrais
saluer l'idée avec lequel nous avons
travaillé sur ce texte avec l'ensemble
de l'association des maires de france
c'est présent baroin en particulier qui
m'a découragé le faire expliquant que à
son avis la libre administration des
collectivités locales et la
responsabilité politique des élus ne
devait pas être nié et que l'article 72
de la constitution se regarder des deux
côtés alors pour résumer monsieur le
sénateur jeu des élus peuvent prendre
des dispositions
soutenu par l'état conforme au droit
dans le règlement intérieur et je pense
que ça va avec la liberté et la
responsabilité de chacun et ils me
trouveront toujours à leurs côtés pour
les soutenir
ça c'est effectivement au clientélisme
merci monsieur le ministre monsieur
goutard pour explication de vote
oui merci merci madame la présidente je
suis un peu étonné effectivement parce
par cet amendement
j'ai bien compris fin je voulais quand
même rappeler que l'élection municipale
était terminée parce que je sens que
c'est un il ya un petit un petit relent
derrière derrière tout ça mais mais mais
clairement sur sur cet amendement
en fait à part à part faire le buzz à
part je dirais remuer un petit peu les
choses
à quoi il sert puisque comme qu'on
m'explique une fois pour toutes si cet
amendement peut s'appliquer
d'abord le ministre a raison de rappeler
que les principes de neutralité
s'appliquer pour les agents mais
absolument pas pour les usagers et que
pourquoi on reviendrait sur les piscines
pourquoi par par d'autres on voit bien
que la direction qui est qui est tenu
dans cet amendement ne tient absolument
pas ne tient absolument pas la route
et donc ce principe du fait que les
usagers du service public ont le droit
d'exprimer leurs convictions religieuses
ou tout autre dans les limites du
respect de leur bon fonctionnement les
impératifs de sécurité de santé et
d'hygiène
ça me paraît assez clair ensuite il ya
des règlements qui sont mis en place
dans la piscine et que c'est à travers
ces règlements et que oui à une
responsabilité des maires parler de
grenoble il me semble qu'un règlement
dans la piscine que les personnes qui
ont souhaité et qui ont fait une action
ne sont pas rentrés il me semble donc la
réponse a été très clair et très simple
mais moi j'irai plus loin puisque
comment du coup cet amendement peut
s'appliquer quand on a un maillot de
bain couvrant d'accord expliquez moi ce
qui a deux religieux dans un maillot de
bain couvrant dans une piscine mais je
vais plus loin dans une piscine dans une
piscine on se couvrir la tête on se
couvrent la tête donc juridiquement
comment vous allez expliquer ça et que
ce que c'est cet accoutrement
du coup à une connotation religieuse
c'est clairement impossible
deuxièmement si on se renseigne un petit
peu sur les associations bien sûr que
les associations qui demandent pour des
raisons religieuses mais il y en a
d'autres moi j'en ai rencontré beaucoup
d associations d'handicapés des
associations de personnes âgées des
personnes tout simplement des femmes des
hommes qui ne se sent pas bien dans leur
corps qui souhaite aller à la piscine
mais qui ne souhaite pas montrer leur
corps ça oui ça existe ça existe ça
s'appelle l'inclusion et donc je pense
qu'on doit aussi également y réfléchir
et je prends un exemple de la mairie de
rennes
la mairie de rennes et la responsabilité
des maires qui a pris d'ailleurs à
travers son règlement qui autorise un
maillot de bain ou dans trois sites à
l'étude
la parole à me ce mardi s'il vous plaît
merci madame la présidente
d'abord un point de méthodes sur cet
amendement qui avait ça a été rappelé
par madame le rapporteur était repoussée
par la commission et qui subitement a
été rétablie par celle ci dans des
conditions qui peuvent prêter un certain
questionnement sur sur le fond cet
amendement pose de nouveau la question
qu'est ce qu'un signe religieux
comment définir un birkin y est ce qu on
le définit exclusivement par la personne
qui le porte et sous-entend que dès lors
qu'elle le porte
elle a nécessairement et obligatoirement
des arrière pensées
c'est un véritable problème de définir
le fait de manifester ostensiblement ses
convictions religieuses par un vêtement
notre part qu'allez vous faire
quand une personne je caricature à peine
réveillé avec un tatouage manifestants
ses convictions religieuses vous allez
lui enlever soyons un peu sérieux ce
n'est pas ce n'est pas la manifestation
par un vêtement ou autres qui définit la
radicalité ou non ceci en femmes et
contraire aux principes que nous
souhaitons défend le principe de laïcité
ne serez permettre une interdiction
générale et absolue de port de tels
signes dans l'espace public sans
remettre en cause des libertés
fondamentales de liberté d'expression et
liberté de religion
dès lors le port du burkini par des
femmes fréquentent en espaces publics
tels qu'une piscine municipale s'il
constitue effectivement une
manifestation de la religion ne peut
faire l'objet d'une interdiction
générale et absolue
je crois que c'est important de s'y
tenir monsieur rhdp ue pour explication
de vote
madame la présidente sioniste bien sûr
nous allons soutenir l'amendement de
michel savin qui a reçu un avis
favorable de notre commission
je voudrais simplement dire que je sais
par coeur et on le sait bien
monsieur je vous l'avais rappelé dans un
cas récent vis-à-vis de l'île de france
mais l'observatoire de la laïcité
s'était déjà prononcé en indiquant qu'on
pouvait interdire le burqini par des
règles et règlements intérieurs sur les
piscines publiques pour des raisons
sanitaires d'hygiène ou de sécurité
moi j'estime que c'est une ruse c'est
une habileté que c'est une hypocrisie
c'est une hypocrisie mes chers collègues
on est là pour réaffirmer le respect des
principes de la république
dans un contexte difficile on en a déjà
parlé deuxième élément monsieur le
ministre vous nous dites que les usagers
du service public ne sont pas contraints
à des obligations de neutralité si la
loi de 2004
pour un enfant mineur ou pour un élève
majeur on est bien d'accord donc
l'assertion qui consiste à dire que la
contrainte de neutralité ne peut pas
s'appliquer aux usagers des services
publics à trouver dans la loi de 2004
une contradiction
les choses doivent être absolument clair
ensuite vous dites que le burqini est un
signe religieux
il y a beaucoup beaucoup de compatriotes
musulmans qui nous indique que ces
accoutrements sont tout sauf des signes
religieux qu'ils n'obéissent à aucune
prescription religieuse
je voudrais citer je voudrais citer le
témoignage lors d'un procès récents le
procès de jean pierre robin ancien
inspecteur général de l'éducation
nationale vis-à-vis du président de la
fcpe procès gagnés et mohamed sifaoui
qui est un des bons spécialistes en
france des mouvements notamment
salafistes déclarait le voile et ils
restent ne sont pas des symboles
religieux sont des écoutes remet en
pensée par les islamistes ont que on
voit bien que derrière ces accoutrements
c'est pas tellement le signal religieux
c'est le signe d'une contre société qui
se veut sexistes qui dit aux femmes
qu'elles sont inférieures à l'homme qui
dit qu' il faut que les femmes se
soumettent et qui veulent séparer une
communauté des croyants de la communauté
des citoyens de la communauté nationale
et enfin chers collègues il s'agit pas
non plus je l' ai entendu de l'interdire
dans l'espace public il s'agit
simplement de l'interdire dans des lieux
qui sont des lieux particuliers fermé
lépi monsieur retail et affiner votre
sociale je suis désolé mais paris comme
un des leurs
merci fonctionnement de celle ci
monsieur de belles mais vous avez
demandé la parole et je vous la sède
[Applaudissements]
merci madame la présidente monsieur me
chers collègues
ce matin la commission a émis un avis
défavorable sur l'amendement burqini
visant à interdire le burqini il a été
légèrement modifié et représenter ce
soir à l'ouverture de la commission je
suis pas certain que nos collègues qui
étaient présents ce matin majoritaire
apprécie beaucoup la manoeuvre c'est la
seconde fois sur ce texte en commission
cette manoeuvre a lieu et l'avis de la
commission ce soir de mon point de vue
aurait dû être que cet amendement
modifié est contraire à l'avis de la
commission de ce matin passons sur la
forme qui est néanmoins est très
discutable sur le fond je serai très
bref la liberté d'expression et la
liberté religieuse ne souffre aucune
exception souffre une essentiellement
qui est le trouble à l'ordre public
nous sommes là si nous adoptons cet
amendement en train de créer un
précédent
il n'y en a aucun autre même le voile
sur la voie publique sur l'espace public
son interdiction reposait sur d'autres
fondements qui qui est essentiellement
la halle exigences minimales de la vie
en société
on doit voir les visages mais là nous
aurions en train de créer un précédent
qui est que sur un motif peut être
louable compréhensible à titre
individuel nous interdisons de manière
pur harbi de manière très arbitraire en
tant que législateur la liberté
d'expression et la liberté religieuse
peut-être que cette liberté lorsqu'elle
s'exerce ne nous plaît pas néanmoins la
liberté de religion la liberté
d'expression et la liberté d'expression
religieuse ne peuvent souffrir aucune
autre modération que le trouble à
l'ordre public et l'atteinte aux droits
d'autrui
si monsieur ben asher
madame la présidente monsieur le
ministre ce présent à cannes mission mes
chers collègues je vais évidemment
soutenir l'amendement de michel savin et
avant de faire des remarques à la
commission sur une procédure tout à fait
légale encore faut-il être sur soi-même
de siéger au bon endroit
ce qui est certain c'est mieux quand
j'entends monsieur gontard à juste titre
défendre son coreligionnaire de grenoble
je le comprends parfaitement
c'est normal c'est de la politique mais
là où je ne suis pas d'accord c'est
effectivement de faire l'autruche
vous faites exactement l'autruche en dix
ans mais n'ont rien à voir entre le
burkini rien à voir avec tout ce qui
pourra être islamisme
alors ça vraiment on se trompe
complètement ici c'est en doute
effectivement un accoutrement
folklorique à caractère de déguisements
pour carnaval pas du tout monsieur
grootaers vous le savez très bien et
parce que vous voulez défendre toutes
les minorités y compris celles qui sont
indéfendables vous en arriver à de
telles positions et c'est parce que ici
nous sommes tous et nous l'avons dit
dans les propos liminaires tous attachés
à la république et j'ai parfaitement en
tête notamment l'excellent discours du
président karoutchi nous voulons nous
sommes tous pour une république unie
nous savons tous qu'il ya des coups de
canifs comme il l'a dit je cite ces mots
et vous en redonner non pas un coup de
canif
mais les coups de machette dans le
drapeau de la république française et
c'est ça qui est scandaleux c'est le
continuer à faire l'autruche et de
laisser les choses envahir moi je veux
la république française telle qu'elle
est faite défini dans la constitution
madame boyer a demandé la parole
résidente monsieur le ministre mes chers
collègues je me permets juste de
rappeler que ce matin en commission
nous avons bien dit que cet amendement
serait rédigée et donc c'est normal
qu'ils étaient présentés tout à l'heure
mais je voulais vous parler simplement
cet amendement et de ce qu'il signifie
alors bien évidemment le burqini c'est
pas une tenue de baignade qui manifeste
une opinion religieuse qui s'ancre rey
dans une légitimité ancien puisqu'il est
né en australie dans les années 2000
néanmoins on sait de quoi il est le nom
le burqini c'est un interdit de
fraternité c'est un interdit d'égalité
c'est un interdit de liberté parce qu'il
est là pour séparer les hommes des
femmes
il est là pour signifier qu'une femme
doit porter une tenue parce que cette
tenue c'est le signe qu'elle est pudique
et que les autres sont un public
comment voulez-vous aujourd'hui que
c'est au nom du principe d'égalité entre
les hommes et les femmes on puisse
soutenir dans notre pays
de telles choses c'est contraire à nos
principes constitutionnels et jonque je
pense qu'il s'agit bel et bien d'une
tenue qui a une portée politique qui
renvoie donc comme je disais tout à
l'heure à la notion d'impudeur et qui
serait propre au corps féminin et à ce
titre le burqini est contraire à ce
principe d'égalité entre les hommes et
les femmes
il est contraire à nos premiers
principes constitutionnels et à ce titre
là il est tout à fait dans le texte que
nous examinons aujourd'hui sur les
principes de la république
mes chers collègues on peut pas sans
arrêt défendre les qualités des hommes
et des femmes ce qui est normal et c'est
notre devoir j'allais dire que c'est
notre adn
à tous ici sur tous les bancs et
supporter aujourd'hui qu'on divise le
monde entre les publics et les
impudiques ça ce n'est pas possible
et la pression qui est exercée sur les
femmes est insupportable c'est à nous de
les défendre
et puisque nous sommes dans le principe
d'égalité je me permettrez de citer à
nos collègues qui nous a précédés sur
les bancs du parlement
c'est henri dominique lacordaire qui
disait qu entre le fort et le faible
c'est la liberté qui opprime
c'est le cas aujourd'hui et c'est la loi
qui protège donc pour protéger l'égalité
entre les hommes et les femmes
il faut voter l'amendement qui michel
sabbah et chaque collègue madame taïbo
reliant vous avez demandé la parole je
crois merci madame la présidente
monsieur le ministre mes chers collègues
je crois madame boyer pour protéger ou
pour faire avancer l'égalité entre les
femmes et les hommes il y a beaucoup de
choses extrêmement urgente affaire et
celle ci ne me semble pas être le cas
pourquoi pourquoi parce que je pense que
le sexisme
c'est aussi de dire aux femmes ce
qu'elles doivent ou non porté donc à
partir du moment où nous rentrons sur ce
débat là si madame je le crois je crois
que quand on rentre dans ce débat là on
rentre effectivement dans un peu la
police du vêtement et à un moment on va
dire ne portait pas si un moment ne
portait pas ça et que donc il ne faut
pas rentrer là-dedans que l'on soit fan
de cette tenue ou pas quelles que soient
nos convictions personnelles je pense
qu'il ne faut pas rentrer là dedans
par ailleurs si effectivement il y a
dans les piscines un problème d'hygiène
par rapport à ce type de tenue comme il
peut y avoir un problème d'hygiène
vis-à-vis d'autres types de tenue eh
bien il faut il faut le dire il faut le
dire très précisément mais ne pas se
cacher derrière cela d'une manière
hypocrite
pourquoi sinon effectivement on donne le
sentiment d'une discrimination qui vise
une population spécifique et je vais
vous dire ce que ça produit ça produit
qu'on pousse un certain nombre de
personnes dans les bras des radicaux est
donc en fait on produit l'effet inverse
ce qui est oui je vous le dis c'est mon
point de vue pouvait le respecter de
ceux qui de ce qui est recherché
enfin et cela a été très bien dit par
d'autres le respect des principes de la
république c'est effectivement de porter
ce qu'on veut dans l'espace public y
compris dans des espaces fermés qui sont
des services publics sauf s'il ya une
contrariété à l'ordre public ce qui
n'est objectivement pas le cas en
l'espèce
pour toutes ces raisons bien entendu
nous ne pouvons pas voter cet amendement
il nous reste une dizaine de prises de
parole monsieur bénard us a demandé la
parole pour explication de vote
merci madame la présidente je sens mes
collègues un peu tendu sur le sujet yala
be more aux voiles bon je le regrette
parce que le débat vu de l'extérieur
pourrait paraître un peu surréaliste en
fait personne ici défaut le burqini
l'automne burqini c'est la question ne
s'est même pas posée pour nous
simplement nous disons deux choses la
première c'est que ce règlement et enfin
7 cet amendement est inapplicable
pourquoi est-il inapplicable pour une
raison je vais vous citer un petit
exemple personnel je m'excuse je reviens
souvent sur des exemples personnel j'en
suis désolé mais j'ai pas l'historique
que vous avez peut-être au sénat donc je
je me réfère aux territoires je connais
à ma famille il se trouve que je suis
issu d'une famille ou ma grand mère ma
mère mes tantes oui ça vous fait
peut-être rien mais je vous dis puisque
c'est la réalité et ça vaut beaucoup
d'arguments que j'ai entendu oui oui
elle est née en 1892 à mascat en algérie
à la doré se baigner ainsi que ma mère
essaie et les personnes de sa famille et
elle se baignait tout le temps avec des
maillots de ballons et des tenues
langues y compris à la piscine en france
et elle aurait été vraiment désolé de
pas pouvoir se baigner parce qu'elle
n'aurait pas changé de tenue et donc
quelles lois eu laure auriez vous
appliquez vous cherchez à combattre le
burqini c'est comme si vous en voyez une
bombe atomique pour éteindre un incendie
ou pour abattre
djihadistes en arabie saoudite chers
amis donc il ya une disproportion énorme
entre ce que vous proposez et la réalité
de l'objectif que vous voulez atteindre
de la même façon l'hypocrisie n'existe
pas lorsque nous défendons le fait que
ce règlement est inapplicable
elles existent lorsque vous cherchez à
attaquer à certains nombres de dati de
la laïcité parce que vous chercher
uniquement à combattre et ça je peux le
comprendre un certain nombre de
mouvements qui sont des mouvements
effectivement qui met en péril notre
démocratie et notre république
mais à admettez que cette règle là n'est
pas applicable en l'état personne ne
pourrait la définir les seuls critères
qui permettraient d'interdire un certain
nombre de choses par exemple l'hygiène
ou les troubles de l'ordre public
nous les avons déjà dans nos loin dans
nos règlements
chez le questeur ce faire vous avez
demandé la parole c'est donc à vous
madame la présidente monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues
oui j'ai demandé la parole parce que
j'ai trouvé qu'il y avait quelques
problèmes intellectuels dans le fait que
depuis tout à l'heure
domine dans cet hémicycle les
considérations à caractère textile et
ces considérations textiles sont liés si
j'ai bien compris à la question de
signes religieux de religion et je suis
très étonné parce que enfin mes chers
collègues il est important de connaître
les religions ça fait partie de
l'histoire de l'humanité on doit
l'enseigné dans les écoles
établissements publics
et s'il vous arrive de lire par exemple
le coran et je me réfère à pas mal de
connaisseurs d'intellectuels il n'est
pas dans le coran
deux mentions de toutes ces
considérations textile alors quand on
dit religion est ce qu'on se réfère aux
textes fondateurs d'une religion dans ce
cas là vous aurez bien du mal à
justifier votre position ou alors est-ce
qu'on se réfère à autre chose les moeurs
mais dans ce cas là si vous vous référez
au mars
on parle plus de signes religieux mais
il faut choisir ou bien vous parler de
religion et dans ce cas il faut que
votre discours est un sens ma rapport
aux religions ou alors on parle des
moeurs et on peut parler des morses
mais cet autre chose dont je trouve
qu'on est dans la confusion
vraiment on peut croire dans des
religions dans une religion ne va croire
est ado stick mais réduire dans tous nos
discours le fait religieux leurs
croyances religieuses à des
considérations textile ça n'a aucun sens
merci monsieur président karoutchi c'est
à vous oui madame la présidente monsieur
lis moi je veux rassurer monsieur
benarroch ma grand mère qui est né au
maroc et aussi ne se baignait que
totalement à billets sauf que monsieur
benarroch comme ma grand mère le faisait
ce n'était pas un geste symbolique
c'était un geste personnel elle n'en
faisait pas un combat contre la
république
elle n'en faisait pas un geste qui était
une provocation par rapport à skier le
consentement légal entre hommes et
femmes en france
c'était sa vie mais n'en faisait pas un
combat aujourd'hui quand on dit le
burqini sincèrement enfin j'ai entendu
des choses que je vous dise bien sûr que
si si on n'avait pas la montée de
l'islamisme
si on n'avait pas les provocations
permanence depuis des années sur un
certain nombre de sujets
qu'est-ce que vous voulez que ça fasse
aux gens que quelqu'un soit tout habillé
dans la piscine ou dans la mer peut être
un problème d'hygiène d'accord mais ça
n'était pas un élément de provocation
mais en réalité et tout le monde le sait
c'est pas la peine non plus d'être naïf
quand même tout le monde sait que le
burqini est très vite devenu pour des
associations islamistes
un élément de combat un élément qui a
été une provocation permanente et à
partir de là quand on dit ah non on ne
peut pas l'interdire c'est donner raison
à ceux qui utilisant des armes contre la
république
finalement découvre la faiblesse de la
république parce que la faiblesse de la
république c'est parfois je les dis dans
mon intervention
c'est de dire au nom de la liberté au
nom de la démocratie
on accepte les provocations on accepte
les dérapages et à partir de là vous
rentrez dans un système où la république
doit se défendre à un moment sinon un
moment il sera trop tard parce que
beaucoup de geste auront été faits et
beaucoup de gestes ont été acceptés à
tort monsieur le ministre j'ai entendu
tout à l'heure et je voudrais en
conclure par là votre démonstration et
j'ai failli me dire il a raison il a
raison pourquoi faire la loi c'est le
pouvoir des élus etc
mais vous avez dit vous même et je vous
en remercie que vous aviez soutenu la
présidente de la région ile de france
mais dans la présidente de la région ile
de france a pris ce règlement la voix
l'a attaquée par la défenseure des
droits
c'est bien que la loi n'est pas si
claire et que oui je sais bien je sais
bien mais enfin pour que la défenseure
des droits attaque la région et la
présidente de rage on sait bien qu'en la
matière il ya des choses à éclaircir
et c'est ce texte de loi
présidente
je donne la parole à présent monsieur
très riche merci le président
effectivement on passe beaucoup de temps
sur des considérations liées à
l'habillement d'ailleurs dire d'abord
dire au président voyou qu'il faut pas
interpréter la loi de 2004 à l'envers ce
qu en effet s'il ya une distinction
entre les enfants et les adultes
c'est tout simplement pour m justement
les enfants à l'abri du prosélytisme et
des pressions et c'est ce qui explique
justement le fait que bien entendu on
fait attention pour eux c'est pal
inverse et celle inverse que vous que
vous avez dit maintenant sur le sur le
burqini il ya quelque chose de
complètement disproportionnée et ensuite
il ya un autre aspect ces concours
derrière quelque chose une fois que pour
reprendre la formule d'aristide briand
et du tailleur une fois que ce ne sera
pas le birkin le burqini ce burqini sera
interdite il y aura une nouvelle
manifestation et il faudra une nouvelle
loi pour tenter d'endiguer les choses on
court derrière les phénomènes et encore
une fois encore une fois il faut arrêter
les caricatures est-ce que ici dans cet
hémicycle l'une ou l'un d'entre nous
veut favoriser l'islam radical en france
la réponse est bien entendu non est ce
que l'islam radical est un danger bien
entendu bien entendu ceci étant faut-il
pour cela remettre en cause tous les
principes sur lesquels sont fondées
cette république dont vous vous prévalez
c'est à dire remettre en cause la
liberté de religion la liberté
d'expression bien sûr que non bien sûr
que non et on entre là dans un engrenage
qui devient délirant mais qui pour
autant parce qu'il n'est pas nommé c'est
toujours
le problème de ce texte nous n'arrivons
pas et vous n'arrivez pas à capturer la
réalité de ce que vous voulez combattre
et on prend des mesures générales qui
auront des conséquences sur tout et sur
tous alors qu'elle ne vise qu'une
minorité et sa fin
c'est le contraire de la loi merci chers
collègues je passe la parole à monsieur
bonnecarrère
merci madame la présidente ses collègues
aucun de nous n'est naïf à l'égard du
burkina et je comprends totalement
l'expression qui a été celle de nombreux
intervenants du groupe des républicains
qui se font les porte paroles d'un vif
agacement de nos concitoyens une fois
qu'on a dit c'est ce que nous avons un
problème pour moi il n'y a pas de
problème il y a eu un problème
cette question a été réglée dans ma
connaissance la quasi-totalité des
collectivités de notre pays des
règlements intérieurs ont été pris soin
sur le terrain de l'ordre public soit
sur le terrain de la sécurité
ce n'est plus en 2021 à ma connaissance
sur ce que je peux voir dans les
territoires un sujet si effectivement
une collectivité et je vous en donne
acte volontiers pour des raisons
politiques
je veux prendre le contrepied de ces
dispositions est introduit des
dispositions et qui sont contraires à
l'intérêt général et qui sont basées sur
une logique particularité particules
particulière séparatistes de la société
les principes qui figurent dans les
dispositions de cette loi
répondront tout à fait et permettront le
jeu du contrôle de légalité
une fois que ces dix ou cela deux
observations par rapport aux porteurs de
de cet amendement il faut quand même
être raisonnable
premier élément vous avait argumenté
collectivement avec une force
incontestable vous avez obtenu 170 voix
sur le fait
que des règles particulières devait être
appliquée pour les accompagnants de
sorties scolaires
parce que ils étaient des agents
bénévoles du service fuite et vous nous
avez démontré que n'étant pas des
usagers on devait leur appliquer ces
dispositions là pour les piscines vous
ne demandez pas l'application de la
règle de neutralité uniquement pour les
mêmes nageurs sauveteurs ou pour le
directeur de la piscine vous le demander
pour les usagers dont vous voyez bien
niveau de contradiction entre ce que
vous nous avez indiquée avec conviction
avant dîner et l'après et vous en êtes à
ce point conscient que vous avez
complété je vais très bien écouter
monsieur président en dix ans mais en
fait ce ne sont pas des signes religieux
parce que c'est un accoutrement et ça
c'est un autre problème
nos difficultés collectives j'en termine
le président pour le ministre c'est
qu'il n'ya pas d'islam à la française
c'est ce que nous voudrions constitué
avec une 10e qu une distance par rapport
aux dispositions mais de grâce ne nous
mettons pas nous-mêmes a interprété le
coran et entend donner notre à prendre
la situation en main qui caresse la
parole maintenant on a les mêmes
benbassa merci madame la présidente
d'abord je voudrais poser une question
combien de femmes se baignent tél ambühl
qui dit nous n'avons aucun chiffre et
nous discutons
ce matin nous avons discuté plus on va à
peu près une heure
et là ce soir on recommence alors
qu'est-ce que qu'est ce qu'on cherche
c'est ça que je voudrais savoir
moi je dirais même j'utiliserai le mot
d'un des élèves qui dit ce film elle me
cherche il me cherche
mais qu'est ce qu'est ce que vous voulez
des musulmans je voudrais savoir
exactement quand c'est pas le bull
qu'amis et le voile quand c'est pas le
voile c'est l'oral alcan c'est pas leur
halal c'est autre chose
mais qu'est ce que vous voulez vous a
souvent tu as lease et le mini
pourparlers
à voir la cause des femmes pour parler
du groupe imi madame boyer je vous ai
déjà répondu ce matin
excusez moi regarder le l'hémicycle nous
ne sommes pas les égales des hommes nous
sommes que tu apprennes 30 % de femmes
dans un hémicycle où il y à 70 vous s'en
donne alors vous n'allez pas maintenant
à vous de venir là l'égérie de la du
féminisme pour le combattre le burkina
plus on poussera à bout les musulmans
plus il y aura de gens qui vont
s'engager dans le salafisme et dans dans
d'autres mouvements fanatiques
parce que vous ne les laissez pas vivre
tout est un objet pour vous d'un
critique de rejet et jusqu'à quand vous
allez continuer à agir de cette façon là
je vous le demande parce que vous
n'arriverez pas à auron d'accord mais
vous perdrez je crois parce que vous ne
voulez pas comprendre qu'aujourd'hui ce
n'est pas seulement des signes religieux
non c'est aussi des c'est aussi aux
revendications identitaires qui peut ne
pas être religieux comme il peut la voir
quand même des religieuses et des
religieux qui revendique cela comme un
combat politique mais alors faisons la
distinction raison la distinction nous
ne voulons pas vivre cet arrêt des
musulmanes
ces laïcs quelle est la différence
moi j'ai dans mon bureau une jeune femme
qui travaille elle a décroît à son conte
des grosses coin
samedi le cheval sharks je donne un
loyer maintenant la présidente eliane
acessible madame la présidente vous avez
la parole merci madame la présidente
mes chers collègues si je peux me
permettre je crois qu'il va falloir
revenir à l'objet de ce texte
et quoi qu'on en pense
et vous savez bien je les dis dans ma
dans l'intervention générale je pense
que certes ce débat est sérieux mais qui
n'est pas qu'il n'était pas urgent alors
on va pas se mentir
sincèrement ce soir entre nous on va pas
se mentir
et comme ça on va assez vite et de faux
débats où chacune et chacun va y aller
de sa traduction ou de la traduction
qu'il ou elle veut bien donner à tel ou
tel de nu tenue c'est pas ça le débat
il n'est pas là du tout le débat le
débat c'est quoi et pour continuer
justement à ne pas se mentir mes chers
collègues le débat qui nous occupe
depuis la reprise de nos travaux ce soir
en fait ils ressemblent aux débats que
nous avons eus précédemment sur
l'article sur l'article 1er c'est
exactement la même essence
c'est exactement la même idéologie qui
est pointée dans ce dans ce débat alors
pour notre part nous la récusons et nous
demandons effectivement à ce qu'il y ait
un débat sage à la hauteur de ce qu'est
notre haute assemblée et nous le
méritons et nos concitoyennes et nos
concitoyens le mérite et je crains que
ce soir ce que nous offrons au peuple de
france n'est pas à la hauteur de ce que
nous sommes ici au parlement et
particulièrement au sénat alors je vais
vous dire simplement mes chers collègues
assumons
en tout cas nous nous les assumons
assumez vos choix mais n'utilisait pas
ce véhicule pour affirmer une idéologie
qui s'insèrent sincèrement personne de
tromper aujourd'hui sur cette idéologie
elle est véhiculée ce soir comme elle
est véhiculée ces mois derniers
c'est année dernière séjour séjour ces
jours derniers et pour terminer je
voudrais affirmer ici solennellement que
pour ce qui nous concerne ici groupe
communiste républicain citoyen
écologique mais j'imagine aussi pour
gogos collègues ici à gauche
nous aimons la république autant que
vous l'aimez que la chose soit dit
je ne sais pas s'ils ont l'air plus pour
assembler dans un forum au premier on ne
défend pas la république en tapant
dessus comme vous le faites ce soir
parfait monsieur la parole est
maintenant à notre collègue max brisson
merci madame la présidente
le ring est un symbole
pas de l'islam nous sommes tous d'accord
c'est un symbole de l'islamisme c'est à
dire ton projet totalitaire d'un projet
totalitaire a besoin de symboles et il
ne faut pas être naïf
on a bien le symbole totalement
contraire à la république parce qu'il
s'agit d'une tenue qui sépare qui
enferme qui écarte ces terres qui est à
l'opposé des valeurs et des principes de
notre république
je constate que son parti des banques de
ces musiques
il ya toujours de bonnes raisons pour ne
pas combattre cette idéologie pour ne
pas combattre sur totalitaire
à chaque fois que l'on propose quelque
chose vous avez toujours une bonne
raison pour nous dire non et vous n'avez
toujours une bonne raison pour s'opposer
quand vous ne voulez pas le convoque ou
totale itt arrive et puis finalement
vous en être complice
alors je vais prête encore vous choqué
davantage mais moi je me demande où est
partout se trouve aujourd'hui une
certaine gauche qui est celle du combat
républicain la république était rouge ce
fut un combat permanent qui nécessite à
chaque fois de trouver des réponses à
des véritables défis je l'avais dit à la
présidente de la fcpe en son temps si
les forces laïques que ce pays avait eu
dans le passé les mêmes attitudes que
celles que l'on entend ici sur ces
bornes
aujourd'hui je ne suis pas sûr que notre
république aujourd'hui serait et laïque
la laïcité cela n'a jamais été de
l'angélisme
ça a été un combat et ce combat quelle
somme ne voulait plus le musée c'est mon
film euros
[Applaudissements]
encore heureux
mes chers collègues encore quelques
interventions avant de passer au vote
madame lienemann a demandé la parole moi
je suis je pense qu'on ait fait le grand
débat c'est de savoir comment la
république va se défendre elle est
attaquée elle est attaquée il ya des
provocations
il ya des attitudes qui sont dramatiques
il ya des emprises qui s'installe et il
est fondamental de trouver les bons les
bonnes méthodes pour combattre ça et
pour le faire reculer
de ce point de vue on peut avoir une
discussion sur effectivement ce qu'on
peut être considéré le but birkin y le
but qui ni comment s'appelle burkini
bikini ge bon burqini je vous en parlais
tout à l'heure le burqini peut être
considéré vraisemblablement comme une
provocation
la question est de savoir quelle est la
bonne réponse à cette provocation et on
ne peut pas avoir quand on est
républicain
des réponses qui ne ce qui donnerait la
force par le sol interdite par
conformisme vestimentaire ça n'est pas
la bonne méthode
parce que une fois qu'on a fait reculer
la liberté de l'usagé d'exprimer sa
façon de s'habiller et autres sauf à des
motifs de d'hygiène sauf à d'autres
motifs d'ordre public
si à chaque fois qu'une provocation ont
fait reculer nos principes mais sérieux
qui gagne c'est pas nous qui gagnons et
de ce point de vue il est dramatique à
chaque provocation comme tel le taureau
dans le dans le carré rouge
on va foncer pour faire reculer nos
principes à nous
non d'autant pus ce d'autant plus qu'à
au temps où tout ce qu'il ya
ségrégationniste doit être radicalement
convoi comme combattu mais ils vont à la
piscine ces femmes elles sont un pays
d'aller se baigner avec des hommes
pour les plus radicaux des salafistes
donc il peut y avoir une part de
provocation mais c'est leur propre
principe aussi à ces salafistes qui
veulent enfermer les femmes en dehors de
la sphère de la mixité donc au sénat
c'est pas le bon combat
c'est pas la bonne méthode d'autant plus
que comme le disait monsieur
bonnecarrère les collectivités prennent
des mesures localement qui font que
cette provocation fini par faire pschitt
très largement par contre ce qui ne peut
pas être réduit c'est la liberté que
nous défendons et d'ailleurs je découvre
votre soudaine passion pour le fait
qu'il faut libérer le corps de la femme
qui doit être largement mottu alors que
j'ai vécu dans ma jeunesse aliments
l'image
[Musique]
merci madame vous avez puisé notre temps
de parole je donne entendre la pierre
aux oubliettes madame même s'il vous
plaît vous avez épuisé votre temps de
parole
vous êtes tous intéressés pour prendre
la parole sur cet abandon ce que je
comprends mais à un moment donné il va
falloir qu'on avance sur ce texte c'est
important je pense que je vous laisse
tous la parole comme il se doit mais
respectez votre temps de parole
respecter les autres
pierre ouzoulias ce
merci madame la présidente monsieur
ministre chers collègues je suis
intimement persuadé comme comme vous et
j'aimerais que nous soyons tous sincère
sur le caractère universel de l'égalité
entre les hommes et des femmes mai dans
la suite du débat vous verrez vous
trouverez des exceptions pour que ce
principe universel ne s'applique à pas
et notamment quand il quand il s'agira
de l'enseignement j'ai défendu ce matin
en commission un amendement pour que la
mixité soit générale dans tout doucement
et vous m'expliquerez un moment donné
qu' il ya des exceptions
elles sont historiques et elles sont
nécessaires dont vous avez aussi vos
exception chers collègues et votre
pensée n'est pas aussi cohérente que
vous nous le dites
par ailleurs sur l'université sur
l'universalité pardon de des hommes et
des femmes
c'est un principe que moi j'applique en
france et à l'étranger et à l'étranger
et vous savez très bien que il y à des
états dont le salafisme le wahhabisme
est religion d'état
et avec ces états nous entretenons les
meilleures relations du monde parce que
ce sont aussi nos meilleurs clients
d'armement mail à l'universalisme
s'arrête et ce qui est absolument
intolérable en france vous l'acceptez
partout ailleurs sur la planète et on
peut continuer à travailler avec ses
billes alors alors que ces pays vous le
savez bien
ils ont pour religion d'état ce que vous
dénoncez ici et on continue à travailler
avec eux un autre point monsieur
retailleau et c'est un point essentiel
un autre point c'est un point essentiel
je m'interdis je m'interdis absolument
de dire au nom d'une religion ce qui
fait partie de son dogme et ce qui n'en
fait pas partie au nom du principe du
séparatisme
je vous ai dit que nous étions des
séparatistes radicaux c'est aux
religions de s'organiser et c'est pas à
moi de dire si le porte du voile et
musulmans ou pas je m'interdis de la
même façon pour savoir si le célibat des
prêtres ce une bonne chose aujourd'hui
s'il faudrait pas or dany
or d' ordonner des ravines une rabin
moi j'ai entendu que le grand
consistoire de france représentait tout
toute la diversité du judaïsme je ne
crois pas moi j'ai j'ai lu l'entretien
de la rabine qui était qui était
excellent qui montrait qu'elle était
aussi un petit peu un petit peu oublié
ensuite faire l'autruche on en reparlera
pour l'enseignement failli parce qu'en
là sincèrement vous nous donner un
exemple absolu et vous ne voulez pas
regarder la réalité telle que l'a
dénoncé monsieur mise de l'intérieur man
merci ma présidence je vous en prie cher
collègue monsieur le président de la
commission des lois vous avez demandé la
parole certainement pour répondre à
l'interprète interpellation d'arnott de
belles mais je laisse la parole et d'une
façon générale mal la présidence le
ministre devrait faire un point quand
même sur le fonctionnement de la
commission des lois et ne pas laisser
croire que par quelques moyens que nous
aurons pu aurions pu adapter ou adoptés
on aurait contourné le règlement
toujours indiqué à tout le monde que
tous les sénateurs et sénatrices qu'ils
ont déposés sur le texte un amendement
peuvent le modifier
jusqu'au bout c'est jusqu'au moment du
vote il ya aucune difficulté pour cela
c'est dans le règlement qu'en ce qui
concerne notre collègue monsieur max
brisson et notre collègue michel savin
il avait déposé un amendement la
commission dans un premier temps avait
émis un avis défavorable
sous réserve qu'ils soient
éventuellement rectifier pour la séance
l'un et l'autre ont modifié leurs
amendements et nous avons évidemment
refait passer devant la commission qui a
émis alors à ce moment là pour les deux
un avis favorable donc la règle édictée
par le règlement du sénat a parfaitement
été respectée
merci monsieur le président de la
commission des lois pour ce rappel très
utile monsieur ministres n'ont pas
refait je mets donc aux voix monsieur
savant
je merci madame la présidente
simplement pour peut-être expliquer les
raisons de cet amendement
premièrement ce texte le destin nous
débattons ce soir monsieur le ministre
concerne bien le respect des principes
de la république
et mon amendement et tout enfant tout à
fait en phase avec ce projet 1
il faut convaincre soit réaliste
c'est un moment visé tout d'abord à
encadrer et soutenir les mères dans leur
prise de décision
chaque année face à des opérations qui
sont menées par des associations
militantes qui met la religion au dessus
de la république et ne dites pas que ça
se passe pas
chaque année ça se déroule les maires
sont démunis face à ces opérations il ne
faut pas les laisser seuls devant devant
ce pouvoir d'appréciation
parce qu'ils subissent des pressions qui
sont intenables
la preuve c'est qu'ils prennent pas de
décisions sur ce type de manifestation
monsieur le ministre vous avez vous avez
en vous vous êtes renvoyé la balle entre
les élus locaux et l'état les élus
locaux disent c'est à l'état de prendre
ses responsabilités et vous vous nous
dites ce soir c'est au maire de prendre
leurs responsabilités
deuxièmement monsieur le maire que
monsieur le ministre je ne voulais pas
je ne voulais pas je ne voulais pas
focalisé sur une religion mais quand
j'ai travaillé sur ce texte je suis allé
voir des jeunes femmes de confession
musulmane
oui mais il faut pas dire ah je suis
allé les rencontrer
or comment le vivez ce moment là et bien
je peux vous dire mesdames et messieurs
de la gauche que certaines femmes
aujourd'hui subissent des pressions des
pressions d'un des quartiers dpsd
pression de leur vie pour porter ce type
de vêtement qu'est-ce qui se passe
soual quittent les villes ou les
piscines sont phagocytés par ces
associations politiques
soual subissent elles prennent s'est
tenue sous la pression des du quartier
de la famille et de l'environnement
voilà ce que vous voulez et aujourd'hui
c'est la réalité ce qui se passe et
dernier point monsieur le ministre mais
j'aurais aimé que vous mettiez en phase
votre position ou
discours que vous tenez sur le terrain
parce que quand vous êtes sur le terrain
vous vous donnez un discours de fermeté
et aujourd'hui vous avez l'occasion
d'enfoncer le clou pour encore une fois
donné un signe positif au maire et aux
élus locaux
vous passez de cette occasion si le
sujet vraiment dommage la parole étant
qu'au ministre si la demande est bon
monsieur sénateur je pense que c'est pas
simplement leur parce que je constate
que à la fois cet après midi et ce soir
mais c'est évidemment le droit le plus
froid du sénat nous avons fait
finalement deux thèmes d'amendements ces
dispositions qui n'étaient pas dans le
texte proposé par le gouvernement et
dont nous a eu l'occasion déjà de dire
plusieurs fois que comme principe
républicain moi je suis très attaché
monsieur le sénateur à la cohérence de
mon discours j'ai pendant quasiment
quatre ans que je suis mise de ce
gouvernement travaille et je crois avec
ses assauts de très nombreux textes qui
relèvent souvent des collectivités
locales dans le cas des finances
publiques
chacun le sait mais eux aussi dans le
travail que j'ai pu faire que le
parlement à chacun sait que et j'espère
que chacun voit que j'aime la discussion
parlementaire et j'ai autant du matin
midi et soir les sénateurs m'expliquer
sur doute de votre groupe monsieur le
sénateur le respect des élus la
confiance aux élus écoutons les élus
laissons les élus décident et écouter la
ms laisser les libertés locales
s'exprimer et regarder l'article 72 de
la constitution
moi je fais confiance aux élus comme
vous l'avez dit d'astuces révélateur
j'ai été mal une commune dite difficile
où il ya une proportion importante de
personnes qui sont de confession
musulmane
je suis pris mes responsabilités ça n'a
pas empêché d'être élu et réélu au
premier tour en disant non il n'y aura
pas deux
repas communautariser à la cantine non
je serai pas des repas végétariens tout
aspen non j accepte pas d'organiser
hypocritement le vendredi après midi
parce qu'en l'occurrence c'était le cas
des moments où on peut prendre son repos
pour faire sa prière
j'étais vice-président de transports de
la métropole et de la région et j'ai mis
fin à un certain nombre de laisser-aller
qui était auparavant et j'ai refusé dans
la propre piscine municipale pour des
questions de service public quand
d'autres collectivités autour de moi le
faisait ces dispositions
mais être élu c'est avoir la
responsabilité aussi de prendre ses
décisions et monsieur le sénateur moi je
respecte éminemment les maires je leur
dis pas un seul instant que parce qu'il
manquerait ici le courage la de soutien
que ray un jour de la naïveté ou d'un
compromis sions qu'on doit décider à
leur place alors même que j'ai expliqué
notamment en le disant tout à l'heure
devant le président aurelio et au
président karoutchi que la loi permet
justement c'est permettrait pas je
comprendrais votre amendement mais
permet justement de prendre ses
responsabilités donc je crois que il
faut pas avoir un discours différent
monsieur le sénateur en effet d'une
séance à l'autre sur la responsabilité
des élus le président de l'association
des maires de france lui même ne veut
pas de ces dispositions et je vous
recommande monsieur le sénateur de ne
pas apporter de critiques entre la vie
sur le terrain et la vie dans
l'hémicycle parce que quel est le
gouvernement cadix ou baraka city
créé au début des années 2000 quel
gouvernement qui a dissous le ccf
créé au début des années 2000 quel est
le gouvernement est dissous le collectif
cheikh yacine
koné dans les années 90 quand il y avait
des gouvernements responsabilité
quel est celui qui aujourd'hui expulse
parce qu ils le demandaient par le
président de la république
quasiment tous les jours que la
république fait des étrangers en
situation qui sont ef s prt qui ferment
des lieux de culte qui propose la
fermeture de ces lieux de culte alors en
franchement monsieur le sénateur je
l'entendais l'argument sur le burqini
j'ai bien compris que ça a fait sans
doute les heures
son de discussions mais la police du
vêtement n'est jamais une bonne police
en revanche la discussion sur le courage
et la responsabilité de chacun
me semble-t-il c'est être conformes aux
principes de la république et moi je
suis d'une inspiration qu'on pourrait
qualifier de droite en effet mais je
suis d'une droite de la responsabilité
et qui aiment la liberté est
l'expression de la liberté
l'expression des libertés et notamment
des croyances religieuses ne peut pas se
renverser comme ça d'un coup de main
surtout qu'en ce qui concerne deux
compatriotes musulmans parce que là vous
avez raison monsieur le sénateur c'est
qu'on n'attaque pas qu'une seule
religion
aujourd'hui c'est le cas d'une dérive
islamiste que j'ai par ailleurs dénoncé
mais quand le président retailleau dit
que c'est pas avec mon religieux et vota
moment dit que c'est un vêtement
religieux
je ne sais pas croire si ce n'est que à
faire un petit peu de médias et ça me
désole que ça tel débat puisse arrêter
un bout de vêtements alors nous allons
passer au vote sur cet amendement
numéro 2 136 avec un avis favorable de
la commission défavorable du
gouvernement qui votent tour qui
s'abstient qui votent contre
pardon il est adopté nous passons
maintenant à une discussion commune de 6
ha ben non et un sous-amendement
l'amendement 303 présenté par madame
benbassa
madame la présidente mais j'entends
qu'on se taise un peu parce que madame
la présidente monsieur le ministre mes
chers collègues
gardons à l'esprit que la loi de 1905
est une loi de liberté
dès lors il ne revenait pas à l'état
d'organiser les cubes le risque avec ce
projet de loi est de transformer cette
loi en une loi de contrôle de police et
de répression du culte les auteurs de
cet amendement souhaite ainsi réaffirmé
cette vision d'une laïcité positive qui
comme je les dis précédemment à sur la
neutralité des pouvoirs publics à
l'égard du culte et à sierra un
traitement égal à ces diverses
expressions
cet amendement vise à rappeler que la
république qui garantit la liberté de
conscience reconnaît le droit à chacun
individuellement ou collectivement de
manifester sa conviction religieuse en
public tant que l'ordre public est
préservé en même temps les affine la
garantie de la cik neutralité des
personnes exerçant une mission de
service public vis-à-vis de leurs
usagers quels que soient leurs
convictions religieuses
enfin n'oublions pas que parfois le
séparatisme ne n'est pas d'une volonté
d'opposition aux principes de la
république
qu'en revanche ne pouvoir publics pas
leur désengagement dans certains
territoires par le manque de financement
des services publics et par le manque de
considération accordée aux difficultés
de certains français nombreux clé de
même ce séparatisme
il convient donc de réaffirmer qu'il
revient à tout organisme de droit public
ou privé chargé de lait
et question d'un service public de
garantir la mise en oeuvre effective des
principes de liberté d'égalité de
fraternité de dignité de laïcité et de
mixité sociale dans l'exercice de ses
compétences je vous remercie
merci chers collègues la maman 496
présentée par monsieur ravive merci
madame la présidente je lis mes chers
collègues la femme est l'avenir de
l'homme
les pourtant certains chez nous
préfèrent voilée l'avenir pour des
raisons sociales politiques et
religieuses les femmes se couvrent de
gré ou de force la tête et une partie du
visage
elle n'a qu'un si un terrible aveu celui
de l'inégalité entre les hommes et les
femmes cette conception contraire à tous
les principes et maman notre devise
républicaine pourrait rester personnel
s'il n'était pas devenu un enjeu
politique depuis une quarantaine
d'années voile au lycée université au
travail dans la rue vous allez déjà
burqa niqab burqini tant de mots temps
de débat qui n'aurait jamais dû se tenir
en france
peut-être que le jour ne débattrons plus
du voile ne pourrons réfléchir aux
moyens de financer la recherche en vue
de la création d'un vaccin contre un
virus qui nous qui nous pourrit la vie
c'est ce que je vous propose dans cet
amendement interdire le voile dans
l'espace public et mettre fin à tous ces
débats comme ça la règle sera clair le
voilà le voile doit être interdit dans
l'espace public parce que outre son
caractère discriminant il sert
aujourd'hui d'étendard aux
revendications communautaires et
islamistes par son essence même arboré
un voile est un acte séparatistes selon
une étude de l'ifop de 2019
un tiers des musulmans ne le portent
pour revendiquer leurs croyances et sa
supériorité sur notre droit ce qui
constitue déjà une volonté de troubles à
l'ordre public
il n'y a qu'une seule loi en france
c'est celle de la république et qu'une
communauté la communauté nationale pour
les islamistes ne voi constitue aussi un
moyen de pression exercée sur celles qui
ne le porterai pas elles sont
marginalisées moquer parfois insulter et
frapper parce qu'elle refuse de se
soumettre le voile par défaut serait un
rempart contre la violence plus d'une
musulmane sur quatre le porte pour se
sentir en six ans en sécurité il ne
s'agit plus de
par atis mais d'une véritable domination
exercée par les islamistes ils ne
veulent pas vivre en dehors de la
république
ils veulent que la charia supplante nos
lois en commençant par l'asservissement
des femmes
les élus que nous sommes ne peuvent pas
cautionner cette situation nous devons
tendre la main à toutes celles qui ne
rêve que d'une chose être liberté être
libéré pardon et s'affranchir du voile
c'est pour libérer tout les incarcérés
dans une geôle de textile car oui une
étoffe peut tout aussi bien privés de
liberté que les barreaux et pour
éradiquer toute marque de conquête
islamistes que nous devons mes chers
collègues agir en votant cet amendement
l'amendement 146 rectifié bis défendu
par monsieur biya qu merci madame la
présidente monsieur lui je trouvais le
monsieur reporter chars collègues
l'interdiction pour les mineurs de
porter dans l'espace public tout signe
religieux ostensible aurait pu consulter
signal fort envoyé à notre jeunesse
elle aurait pu voir une garantie pour la
préservation de son insouciance de sa
liberté
dans quelle mesure une république laïque
peut-elle tolérer que des enfants
manifestent des signes religieux au su
et au vu de tout le monde
ce n'est pas aux parents d'imposer des
normes ou l'enfant aussi l'essentiel
qu'existent des espaces protecteur pour
ces derniers vecteur d'émancipation le
présent amendement vise à interdire dans
l'espace public le port de signes ou de
tenues par des mineurs manifestant
ostensiblement une appartenance
religieuse dans cette perspective il est
indispensable d'empêcher tout moyenne
des infériorités la aux femmes et
notamment la jeune fille au travers de
nabi ou d'un vêtement qu'on lui impose
nous passons un amendement sous-amendé
nous allons présenter le sous-amendement
numéro 677 par monsieur le rudulier ça
d'abord l'amendement pardon non non non
c'est le sous amendement l'amendement
madame boyer pardon excusez moi dames la
présidente
mesdames messieurs les rapporteurs
monsieur le ministre mes chers collègues
trouverez-vous parler ici des mineurs il
y a quelques jours sur ces bancs je
crois qu'on s'est tous honorés à voter
tous ensemble une un texte pour protéger
les mineurs
c'était l'honneur du sénat et celle et
ex de l'alem billon aujourd'hui je crois
que nous devons nous interroger sur la
symbolique du voile islamique et faire
respecter l'intérêt supérieur de
l'enfant conformément à la convention de
l'onu relative aux droits de l'enfant
que la france a ratifié il ya 30 ans le
voile est fait pour dissimuler le corps
des femmes au regard sexualisé des
hommes
quelle est alors la signification de
voix ligne fillette si les défenseurs du
voile évoque le libre choix des femmes à
le porter quand est-il lorsqu'il s'agit
d'enfants en bas âge ou de jeunes
n'ayant pas atteint l'âge du
consentement le voilement des mineurs
peut représenter des risques pour
l'épanouissement physique mental moral
et social des enfants
l'essayiste iranienne devenue française
chad rock djavann qui a porté le voile
pendant dix ans a écrit un excellent
livre à ce sujet chad rau djavann avait
13 ans en iran quand elle s'est battue
pour ne pas le porter elle a été
emprisonnée pour cela et alors quand
elle croise aujourd'hui une femme qui le
porte
elle dit que ça lui est insoutenable je
la cite elle dit aussi que le voile est
un symbole qui toute capacité à la femme
d'être un être pensant quand elle seule
de ses cheveux peut susciter le désir
sexuel le plus frustré de l'homme elle
est réduite à un appât sexuel ce symbole
pornographiques autorise toute forme de
violence à l'encontre des femmes et les
placent dans le non droit
quand on voit d'une petite fille on lui
inculque que la culpabilité de sa
sexualité féminine
on lui dit que ses cheveux et ses formes
de son corps peuvent à tout moment faire
perdre le contrôle de soi aux hommes je
demande qu au moins dans les pays
démocratiques
le port du voile par des mineurs soient
sanctionnés cela relève des droits de
l'homme et de la protection des mineurs
fin de la citation je voudrais ajouter
également que cet interdit de liberté
cet interdit de fraternité c'est tintin
10 des qualités au-delà du fait qui peut
apparaître comme un symbole d'une
domination patriarcale et de
l'oppression des femmes par les hommes
portent atteinte à
la dignité des enfants de la république
également vous rappeler qu'une telle
mesure il ya la décision du conseil
constitutionnel du 9 19 novembre 2004
qui dit les dispositions de l'article
1er de la constitution aux termes
desquels la france est une république
laïque interdisent à quiconque de se
prévaloir de ses croyances religieuses
pour s'affranchir des règles communes
régissant relations entre collectivités
publiques et particuliers aussi mes
chers collègues j'ai modifié mon
amendement pour ne plus porter
l'interdiction pour ne plus parler
pardon l'interdiction du port de signes
ou de tenues manifestant ostensiblement
une appartenance religieuse dans
l'espace public pour les mineures mais
deux signes allant à l'encontre de la
dignité des femmes
l'art si c'est bien on allait dans le
flou à parce que là on avait déjà
déplacé mais monsieur le rudulier
n'étant pas présent le sous-amendement
n'est pas défendu je passe la parole
madame boyer sur votre 160 rectifier il
est défendu par fait
le 129 rectifié monsieur fialaire oui
madame la présidente monsieur le
ministre le présent amendement vise à
interdire dans les services publics le
port des signes ou tenues par lesquels
les mineurs manifestent ostensiblement
une appartenance religieuse
il est indispensable d'affirmer avec
force que le port du voile pour les
mineurs ne sauraient être tolérés dans
les services publics en particulier car
se pose avec une acuité particulière la
question du lit barbe rythme et du
consentement de celle ci
monsieur le ministre mes chers collègues
lily minuit je vous propose de prolonger
notre séance jusqu'à minuit et demi si
cela vous convient pas plus nous sommes
mardi soir donc pas plus s'il n'ya pas
d'observation il en est ainsi décidé
madame le rapporteur votre avis sur les
différents amendements s'il vous plaît
alors je vais essayer de reprendre
rapidement chacun des objectifs de ces
amendements qui prévoient tous
effectivement la possibilité de ne pas
porter de signes religieux ostentatoires
dans les locaux accueillants aux
services publics ou plus généralement
dans l'espace public donc l'amendement
246 me suis radié temps interdire tout
signe ostentatoire dans tout l'espace
public
l'amendement d'alain delattre prévoit
une telle interdiction dans l'espace
public seulement pour les mineurs madame
boyer qui tend à interdire le port de
signes alors l'encontre de la dignité
des femmes dans l'espace public d'une
manière générale puis l'allemand 160 et
129 quant à interdire les signes
ostentatoires dans les établissements
accueillent le public et un amendement
qui précise seulement pour les mineurs
puis madame benbassa temps affirmé que
la république garantit le droit de
manifester sa conviction religieuse
alors évidemment évidemment ces cds bas
alimentent un débat de france 2 sociétés
profond enfin voila je partage beaucoup
de ce qui a été dit lors de de la
discussion ces amendements
il touche évidemment évidemment entre un
équilibre complexe entre les libertés
individuelles et la préservation de leur
public au travers des exigences na
si mal de la vie en société c'est vrai
c'est vrai ils posent souvent ces
amendements des problèmes d'abord de
qualification juridique
sincèrement je pense que nous les avons
analysé nous avons pour l'instant un
équilibre en ce qui concerne l'espace
public qui par la loi de 2010 interdit
toute la dissimulation du visage dans
l'espace public
certes ça peut paraître insuffisant
certes il y aura proment des choses à
réécrire à écrire il ya des ajustements
ponctuels qui peut être fait on l'a fait
ce soir par exemple avec l'amendement de
mme atzori sont donc aujourd'hui il ya
une vraie difficulté au niveau de la
constitution avec ses amendements et je
voudrais dire aussi que plus
particulièrement sur le voilement des
petites filles et des mineurs
sincèrement c'est un vrai sujet je pense
que personne ne peut s'exonérer cette
discussion
nous allons d'ailleurs avec ma collègue
échanger sur ce sujet lors de nos
auditions
la plupart en particulier des
universalistes des associations qui
défendent tous ces sujets pense qu'il
faudrait faire un texte spécifique sur
ce sujet si il faut pas de jeu laissez
moi juste finir dans le cadre propre
allemand de la protection de l'enfance
en tout cas un sujet qui existe qui nous
heurte tous moi je suis élu de banlieue
donc comme un certain nombre d'élus si
nous constatons cette dérive sur le
voilement des petites filles mais très
sincèrement c'est par ex amante ce genre
d'amendements qu'on peut le régler
c'est important d'en parler c'est
important dans ce 2 signalé mais nous il
faut que nous trouvions en tout cas des
fondements juridiques que nous n'avons
pas aujourd'hui pour le faire
malheureusement je pense que tu es ce un
sujet qui peut revenir
donc c'est vrai que pour tous ces
amendements qui soulève des sujets moi
je vous propose de retirer ces
amendements ou d'émettre un avis
défavorable parce que de toute façon
aujourd'hui il ya des qualifications
juridiques que nous n'avons pas
malheureusement peut-être on peut le
regretter mais en tout cas ces
amendements aujourd'hui vous entendrez
le retrait en tout cas c'est la position
de la commission des lois aujourd'hui
merci
le rapporteur ma vie monsieur le
ministre je vais donc mettre aux voix
ses différents amendements madame boyer
non c'est non non le ministre allez-y
bah oui allez-y pour l'explication de
vote
s'cusez moi pas entendu merci madame
leur apportant pour votre réponse je
voudrais vous dire que le voilement
deminor représente une forme de
maltraitance chez nos enfants il n'y a
pas d'un côté comme je disais tout à
l'heure les enfants pudique et de
l'autre les impudiques
je rappelle que les dérives sectaires
constitutives d'abus de la liberté
d'opinion et de religion mais aussi de
l'ignorance et de la faiblesse d'autrui
ou de mise en en péril des mineurs sont
parfaitement appréhendé déjà par le
droit pénal
allons plus loin aujourd'hui en ayant le
courage de dire non au voile mans des
mineurs mon amendement n'est pas
correctement rédigé
c'est pas le bon texte madame le
rapporteur sous un banc dont nous sommes
là pour faire la loi et pour en étant
bien sûr soucieux des exigences
constitutionnelles et conventionnelles
sur ses bancs il ya les textes majeurs
qui ont été votées je pense à la
reconnaissance du génocide arménien a je
pense au retrait de l'autorité parentale
pour un conjoint violent
anticonstitutionnel un jour
constitutionnel le lendemain je pense à
la présomption de contraintes pour les
mineurs de 15 ans nous avons voté
l'autre jour et concernant le véhicule
législatif je crois mes chers collègues
qui ne faut pas que ce soit un rendez
vous manqué si un texte sur les
violences faites aux mineurs arrive on
rejettera l'amendement en nous disant
article 45 ce sujet c'est pas le bon
moment c'est ce que disait tout à
l'heure
max brisson nous avons ce soir
l'occasion pas demain pas dans un mois
mais ce soir au sénat protéger les
mineurs si j'osais je dirais ici et
maintenant nous voulons lutter contre le
totalitarisme islamique
il faut combattre ce qui en est le
symbole le totalitarisme islamique a
besoin tous les totalitarismes a besoin
de symboles
aujourd'hui se servir des mineurs pour
imposer ce symbole et ne pas ce soir
lorsqu on est là sur les principes de la
république
votez la protection des mineurs moi ça
me semble être le bon texte
c'est le bon moment et il est notre
responsabilité mes chers collègues de
dire ce soir haut et fort que le sénat
ne peut accepter en france qu'une
mineure soit voilée nous devons le dire
aux français nous devons le dire assez
jeune fille et je crois que tous nous
devons le dire à toutes ces femmes qui à
travers le monde risquent à décourage
leur fille leur vie pour refuser porté à
voile pour sentir le vent dans leurs
cheveux
c'est le moment de le faire mes chers
collègues on va pas encore atteint
en droit on va pas encore attendre je ne
sais quel texte
alors que nous voyons parce que vous
dites madame la rapporteure que vous
êtes élu de banlieue
moi je suis élu de marseille et je crois
que partout en france on voit des
petites filles voilées
donc c'est un c'est de la maltraitance
c'est ce et de l'indignité qu'on impose
à ses enfants
donc pourquoi aujourd'hui reculait
encore et nous trouver un autre texte
sur les plus chers de l'algérie on ne
peut pas maltraités si cher dans la vie
je donne la parole à madame lienemann
moi je suis favorable à ce qu'on trouve
une législation qui interdisent le
voilement des mineurs et je partage
l'avis de notre rapporteur
il faut qu'on trouve le support
législatif qui nous permettent d'être
conforme à la constitution et de ne pas
voir retoquer une mesure qui si elle
était retoqué aurait un effet d'annonce
contraire à notre volonté
donc si d'ici là deuxième lecture on
pouvait trouver quelque chose mais je
pense qu'il y en aura pas
donc à partir de là je crois qu'il faut
surtout pas se tromper dans la méthode
utilisée pour arriver à nos fins mais
moi je veux dire qu'en tout cas une
disposition législative devient en effet
maintenant urgente elle ne doit pas être
bâclé ne doit pas être fragilisé
il faut qu'on y réfléchisse rapidement
madame iman monsieur président
retailleau la parole est à vous
rapidement madame la présidente monsieur
le ministre
moi je soutiendrai ces amendements que
madame delattre qui est ce soir la
prison de séance mais aussi que vers les
voiliers ont représenté ce que je crains
je comprends ce que maria lipman vient
de dire ce que je crains c'est que le
texte qu'on nous promet sur la
protection de l'enfance ne viennent pas
dans le calendrier avant longtemps
ce que je crains aussi c'est que si ce
texte venait à s'inscrire dans notre
agenda législatif
on nous sort un article 45 je pense que
si ces amendements n'ont pas fait
l'objet d'un d'une irrecevabilité au
titre d'article 45 de la constitution
c'est donc ils ont un lien avec le texte
c'est la raison pour laquelle je voterai
ses abonnements
merci je vais donc mettre aux voix
successivement les amendements avec deux
avis défavorables pour chacun le 303
amendement de madame benbassa qui votent
pour qu'ils votent contre qui s'abstient
il n'est pas adoptée le 4 196 de
monsieur ravier qui vote pour qui votre
compte qui s'abstient il n'est pas
adopté l'amendement 146 rectifié bis
présenté par le groupe rds ceux qui
votent pour
alors on va couper de 3 12 13
16 17 18 19 27 30 qui votent contre
qui s'abstient il est adopté par nous et
les suivants tombe
[Musique]